[Música]
hola bienvenidos a este programa
especial del debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález esta el poderío
de eeuu como gran potencia mundial en
declive muchos analistas lo han
comenzado a comentar muchos incluso lo
están pronosticando pero cuáles son las
bases para estos argumentos en que están
basando sus teorías en una amenaza
externa ya en los 80 un japón sumamente
industrializado y moderno era
supuestamente la amenaza en esa época en
los 90 era la unión europea y los
fuertes valores democráticos del poder
cultural y económico de ese bloque
europeo en la segunda década del siglo
21 el gigante asiático china es vista
con perspicacia es hoy en día eeuu el
mismo poder militar y económico de las
últimas décadas su poder duro y suave
sigue teniendo el mismo efecto a nivel
mundial está cediendo terreno ante china
o lo que está en declive es su tal vez
no tan inquebrantable democracia que ya
está dando muestras de algunas fisuras o
por lo menos de malestar sobre todo
desde la toma del capitolio a 26 de
enero o desde que el entonces presidente
y también candidato republicano donald
trump argumentó que hubo fraude en las
últimas elecciones presidenciales sin
dar a conocer ningún tipo de evidencia o
también el fortalecimiento de los grupos
extremistas eso nos lleva a preguntarnos
entonces si tal vez la verdadera amenaza
es interna y no externa
eeuu y su imagen de la democracia bien
cimentada está en riesgo lo vamos a
analizar en este programa especial del
debate de france 24 y para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a la doctora heidi
jane smith ella es profesora e
investigadora del departamento de
economía de la universidad
iberoamericana en la ciudad de mexico es
doctora de la florida internacional
university y también es máster en
políticas públicas de la universidad de
la american university también está con
nosotros caillet mccarry él es ex
diplomático estadounidense fue en su
momento responsable de la política
occidental de europa y de derechos
humanos así como de la promoción de la
democracia es ex consejero del director
ejecutivo de la la corporación
financiera internacional para el
desarrollo de eeuu y en el estudio de
france 24 nos acompaña lores winner él
es ex diplomático estadounidense
actualmente es profesor adjunto de la
pontificia universidad javeriana de
bogotá también es consultor
internacional está con nosotros aquí en
el estudio de france 24
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en este debate con
todos sus comentarios y todas sus
preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
las redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook también en instagram en twitter
estamos en todas estas redes como
france24 guión bajo s santi logo que es
mi cuenta personal nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas y pues
teniendo ya un poco el contexto teniendo
ya nuestros invitados doy paso entonces
al debate tenemos muchas cosas para para
analizar el día de hoy en este programa
comienzo entonces con la doctora speed
preguntándole la pregunta base de este
debate está eeuu en una fase de declive
es esto en realidad o simplemente una
percepción que hay a nivel internacional
sobre supuesto aparente declive
pues muchas gracias por la invitación y
qué lindo debate porque si son temas muy
relevantes por las traducidas en el
momento actual yo creo que más bien es
la segunda parte de tu frase es cómo
vamos a preguntarnos cuál es el declive
y cómo se entienden los estados civiles
dentro del sistema global y cómo se
entiende nuestro desarrollo dentro de
eso no solamente dentro en la parte de
dentro de los socios pero también
externamente entonces es importante
tomar en cuenta que esta es la
democracia liberal más importante del
mundo no es una democracia donde empieza
y termina con votación con
representación local con una
búsqueda interna para resolver nuestros
problemas a través de una sistema
liberal democrático con una sistema
capitalista con muchísimos gobiernos que
manejan
a nivel nacional
anderson nacional tanto en el local
entonces hay muchas fases para
desarrollar este debate dentro y fuera a
nuestros niños entonces yo creo que es
importante tomar en cuenta que con la
ganancia de joe biden ya estos niños
están jugando otra vez en el mundo
global y no estamos haciendo trampas
como como hizo el presente anterior ganó
trump en no participar en una visión o
nombrar personas en el sistema del
comercio no hacer juegos con el world
business forma entonces lo que hacen
nuestros niños en ese momento es dos
cosas fundamentales
nombra una nueva y aprueben una
legislación de volver a perder que es
construir dentro de esos niños con
diferentes políticas y podemos hablar
más a fondo de eso y la segundo es una
una nueva legislación que que es la
infraestructura de inversión y
crecimiento y esas dos cosas están
tomando en cuenta son fundamentales para
entender lo la lógica es que ante los
estados ellos para poder actuar fuera
vamos a analizar esos puntos son más en
el programa de autor a smith le doy la
palabra ahora en la ciudad de washington
a que le marcaron sus impresiones que le
está en declive eeuu es una percepción
no es una realidad y hay formas de
fundamentar y de argumentar este
supuesto aparente declive como lo ve
usted
gracias y muchas gracias a usted y
también los otros colegas que nos
acompañan mire en el fondo no no está en
declive eeuu pero sí es un país en
desarrollo como todos los países y lo
que se ve es que en el caso de eeuu todo
lo que pasa
se ve en los primeros primera plana de
los periódicos
y puede hacer dos comentarios breves al
respecto uno es
el hecho de que en este país tuvimos por
primera vez en nuestra historia un
precedente que no quiso acatar a la
constitución ese fue el reto
más grande que ha tenido nuestro país
desde la guerra civil a mediados del
siglo 19
entonces
qué pasó bueno en el fondo las
instituciones fueron por fueron capaces
de manejar esa situación
el congreso a pesar del ataque que
sufrió a manos de los seguidores centro
ser típico al candidato electo que es yo
bailé
y ahora el país
está funcionando con una normalidad
constitucional
y no obstante hay fuerzas en el mundo
que
están dando retos hacia eeuu y
obviamente hay que hablar de china y
podemos profundizar si obviamente
tenemos la situación con rusia sobre
todo con respecto a ucrania
yo creo que parte de lo que el presente
baile está haciendo es trabajando como
le dijo lo dijo la comentarista de smith
para recuperar
la confianza mundial se hace eeuu sobre
todo con nuestros aliados principales
como son europa y japón- claro y dejó
una
una pauta que es que eeuu con estas
pruebas que hemos pasado
está claro que eeuu sigue siendo junto
con nuestros aliados de los países
democráticos que incluye a colombia
el centro de lo que es
un sistema que funciona dentro del
imperio de la ley' clark y entonces esto
es bien importante sobre todo frente a
los retos que tenemos y que le bueno
tenemos un poco menos de 30 minutos para
este tema tan extenso les pido por favor
que sea muy puntuales le doy la palabra
a lawrence
para conocer su opinión para partir ya
en el debate hay un declive no lo hay es
simplemente una percepción pues una
realidad como lo ve usted lawrence a que
en el estudio buenos a diego gracias
nuevamente por la invitación no hay duda
que estamos en un periodo mundial de
transición en ese sentido los eeuu ha
dominado el escenario mundial desde la
caída de unión soviética en el 89
entonces en este periodo este periodo de
unipolarismo está terminando
estamos yendo más para un tipo de ritmo
y tal vez un multi por lo mismo en el
futuro ahora como maneja los eeuu y
manejamos mundial esa transición no hay
duda que también la arquitectura mundial
que menciona el señor me quedé es bajo
el liderazgo y la inspiración de eeuu en
cuanto a apoyo a democracia derechos
humanos lucha contra la corrupción y los
valores básicos que hemos manejado pero
ese aquitectura también está bajo
amenaza estaba en amenaza por el
populismo
de la derecha y de la izquierda y está
bajo una amenaza de china que no
necesariamente comparte estos valores
básicos de la arquitectura mundial
actual
y últimamente por fin como mencionaron
ambos comentaristas aquí está bajo
amenaza en el mismo eeuu liderado por el
grupo alrededor del señor trump que
trató de tumbar una lección y si está
debilitando nuestra fe y confianza en
nuestras propias instituciones
democráticas y eso para mí es la
cuestión si podemos
responder a eso volver a fortalecer y
tener la confianza de nuevo de pueblos
estados niños en esas instituciones y
eso va a ser muy significativo y 'no
para adelante sean aquí en tres temas
resumen tres temas importantes para
dejar sobre la mesa para que hagamos el
debate continuo con lorenza aquí en el
estudio para hacer la ronda a la inversa
usted habla de
la institucionalidad en eeuu que muchas
personas están un poco empezando a ver
con recelo la institucionalidad por los
hechos que han sucedido en los últimos
años en eeuu es entonces la amenaza o
una de las causas de este declive o de
pérdida de fuerza o de posicionamiento
de eeuu a nivel internacional un factor
interno o es un factor ya externa yo
creo que para para eeuu es más un factor
interno que está está como quebrando
poquito a poquito la tela que nos ha
unido por por ciclos de de la confianza
que su gobierno es representativo de los
intereses del pueblo y eso ha sido
amenizado por mucha gente más que todo
por la derecha en los eeuu pero también
por la izquierda y eso estamos viendo en
él
creciendo el populismo que tenemos
dentro de los eeuu
creo que es muy importante que retomamos
esa confianza y esa fe en nosotros
mismos doctora smith él le preguntó
sobre estos comentarios que hace
lawrence aquí en el estudio el populismo
la derecha tratando de hacer más de lo
que se le puede permitir en el marco de
la ley es el factor interna entonces la
amenaza de eeuu en cómo lo ve usted
pues es interesante lo que dice lawrence
y estoy totalmente de acuerdo lo que
está pasando es que la democracia
estadounidense tiene 250 años entonces
estamos viviendo en una sociedad que
está madurando o sea todos los imperios
mundiales han madurado y ahora vemos que
mucho la política estadounidense han
sido normas y no light y si son normas
significa que son cuestiones que siempre
hagamos pero no siempre está en en letra
de pie como debería ser entonces
entonces lo que hemos visto es que aquí
hay una una guerra política dentro de
los demócratas y republicanos en ver
cómo cómo se pueden mejorar el sistema
de elecciones locales nacionales y su
repente de representación lo que ha
hecho en las elecciones de 2020
es la aventura de de lujosos momentos en
donde puedes sacar jugo a donde no estás
fijo en la ley como esto es que es
la parte de la nombramiento de los
representantes en el congreso por
ejemplo pero en otras formas que también
vivimos en una democracia liberal que
que se reinstalen en la propiedad del
propio sistema por ejemplo lo que ha
pasado la semana pasada es que los
votantes en nueva york votaron que los
migrantes por votar ser los ciudadanos
locales aunque no ciudadanos nacionales
de desahucios pero si no la política
local afecta y eso esto siempre ha sido
la ley de eeuu hasta los 230 en nuestros
ciento entonces aunque hay ramos donde
hay como cuestiones también en sus
cuestiones pueden ser que haya mejor
existen los globales y que por ejemplo
está migrante pueden pueden jugar voy a
votar no hasta dos años entonces eso es
interesante
y keith levene nacional de washington su
opinión sobre estos factores internos a
los que está haciendo frente a eeuu
mencionaban en el alcance de la derecha
pero también yo quiero sumar por ejemplo
el factor de la polarización de la
sociedad que lo vimos reflejado en los
resultados de las votaciones
presidenciales fake news hay movimientos
de conspiración la polarización división
social división en el congreso
su opinión bueno
somos todos seres humanos y susceptibles
a estas
tentaciones de meternos en
conspiraciones y todo eso yo creo que lo
que es lo que estamos viviendo es una
época
tan difícil con tantos retos como
hubiera sido la época de los años 30 yo
creo que a partir del desplomó
económico de 2008 junto con
los cambios en la economía de eeuu
a partir de la desindustrialización
que se han provocado en este país
en movimientos y pensamientos que son
más radicales por pero como reacción a
estos acontecimientos
en la derecha es y eso se aprovechó
mucho el expresidente trump existe la
idea de que nuestro país tal y como lo
concebimos está desapareciendo y en la
izquierda existe
la idea de que el país está siendo
controlado únicamente por los intereses
económicos más adinerados y entonces
pero estas son de estos son debates que
han sido permanentes pero el momento si
es un momento difícil para el país y
para el mundo quiero que decirles que
creo que en el fondo lo que lo que está
pasando es que el país está cambiando
personas como yo yo tengo 60 años
muchas personas
como yo y sobre todo personas que viven
al interior del país cuando piensa en
eeuu piensan en un país que es un 90%
blanco y 80% protestante el país no es
así simplemente ha cambiado ha habido
una migración importante de todo el
mundo claro pero especialmente de
latinoamérica y eso ha provocado un
encuentro de nuestros mundos y está
cambiando el país y eso sí
causa
inquietud claro entremos tras mucha
gente y agregado eso a las dificultades
económicas que hemos vivido produce
estos foros populares de populistas de
derecha y de telefe eso va muy en línea
con lo que decía la doctora smith que es
una democracia que está en un estado de
madurez está construyendo todavía es
joven digámoslo así en cierta forma si
se compara con otros estados a nivel
mundial el que ya que usted toca la
relación con con américa latina'
mencionaba américa latina' me salgo de
la parte interna de eeuu para llevar
esto a la parte internacional que es tal
vez el escenario donde más se ha
evidenciado que eeuu ha cedido terreno o
le han ganado terreno a otros países o
bloques a nivel mundial en ciertos
aspectos pero la relación con américa
latina' no sé cuál la perspectiva que
usted tenga pero lo que se siente desde
acá desde la región es que eeuu se ha
distanciado un poco de la región ya no
está tan atento y le ha cedido terreno
por ejemplo a china donde ya es el
principal
aliado comercial de la gran mayoría de
países de la región está en múltiples
áreas haciendo inversiones y eeuu era
digamos el país más cercano con estos
valores democráticos y con este poderío
económico en una región con muchas
necesidades
claro que sí no y eso es eso es cierto
la verdad que por los problemas internos
por otras prioridades internacionales
hemos descuidado la relación con américa
latina y creo que la idea no sería
enfrentar a china en américa latina sino
acercarnos más con nuestros nuestros
vecinos y nuestros los países que de
donde ya la gran cantidad de americanos
prohíben
además además es el vecino natural
geográficamente estamos a la vuelta de
la esquina
si doctoras misak su opinión en torno a
este tema y terminó la ronda con
lawrence ya le voy a dar la palabra a
lawrence para hablar sobre este tema
doctor smith su opinión sobre la
relación con américa latina ha cedido
terreno sin duda con frente a china pues
justamente lo que estábamos hablando
antes no
que los socios están madurando y el
mundo está madurando con los eeuu
entonces no va sola cuestión que el
estado se está dejando américa latina
atrás al contrario tenemos una relación
más sofisticada con américa latina no sé
cómo vivimos con esa democracia liberal
convivimos con una necesidad de apoyar
lo que en sistemas capitalistas entender
que los extremos democráticos son
complicadas entender que traer la
inversión es complicada los estados años
y la pregunta del debate es declive las
personas pero lo que se entiende ahorita
en américa latina mi punto de vista es
que se entienden los mismos problemas
américa latina que sintiendo eeuu
sociales tenemos unas del sistema de
es en su estructura de 3 número 13
estamos en la educación pública número
13 en la sistemas pizzas por ejemplo
entonces tenemos unos problemas graves
en el sentido que no somos el primero en
todo pero eso también esta humanidad
para entender qué es complicado atraer
inversión es difícil de ese crecimiento
y ahorita estamos en una situación post
crisis pandemia y en una alta inflación
y complicaciones también en términos de
nuestro
propio ente realmente nuestro nacional
entonces convivimos con los mismos
formas que varios países de américa
latina pero tenemos los mismos valores y
esos valores son importantes para seguir
adelante en el futuro con las
poblaciones con esos países maduros con
nosotros lawrence retomando lo que dice
la doctora smith hay una evolución hay
un cambio lo ha dicho ya varias veces y
se comparten valores tal vez lo que se
nota acá es que tal vez ese modelo
intervencionista que tenía eeuu
anteriormente ya no es el modelo para
aplicar dado el escenario en el que se
encuentra américa latina o el mundo en
este momento y se está cambiando lo han
mencionado también los otros invitados
el mundo está cambiando como puede ser
entonces esa nueva relación con américa
latina' teniendo ya china muy bien
posicionado en la región entendiendo que
el intervencionismo no es el modelo para
actuar como puede ser entonces la
presencia eeuu aquí es una muy buena
pregunta de santiago y yo creo que
podemos empezar lo que comentó que lo
brevemente que no podemos estar en
competencia con china la región no
podemos volver a otra guerra fría cuando
era la unión soviética contra nosotros
peleando por influencia lo que tenemos
que ver son nuestros intereses
nacionales que son muy importantes en
esa región y yo creo que el crítico es
válido que hemos dejado eso hemos sido
desde la caída del muro más defensivo
protegiéndonos contra la droga
protegiéndonos contra la inmigración el
terrorismo el terrorismo pero no hemos
sido tan
protagonista en lo positivo venciendo la
profesora igual que no podemos ser
protagonista en cuestión de intervención
militar es nuestro mundo de hoy pero si
podemos ser más protagonismo
en apoyar los gobiernos democráticos
abrir los mercados que hemos podido he
perdido un poquito de influencia no te
vamos si seguimos siendo el mercado el
mejor inversionista en latinoamérica
pero es inversión privada nunca vamos a
poder competir con la inversión pública
que tiene la china actualmente pero si
podemos buscar más oportunidades de
abrir los mercados y apoyar las
democracias luchar contra la corrupción
en la región
que es nuestro natural fuerte si lo
vemos así el doctor smith pasó a
preguntarle por china ya llegamos al
último bloque del programa china es la
gran potencia económica a nivel
internacional todos los países a nivel
mundial
quieren tener algún tipo de relación
comercial con china así no compartan sus
valores políticos pero a nivel comercial
es un mercado inmenso que todos los
países quieren estar allí
desde su perspectiva hay una competencia
de modelos cree usted que eeuu está
todavía tratando de imponer este modelo
democrático este modelo de libertad y
está compitiendo con este modelo que
muestra china un país comunista pero
económicamente
abierto a la inversión y muy parecido a
un modelo capitalista por lo menos en
términos económicos el otro los otras
áreas las podemos discutir
pues yo no veo competencia yo al
contrario veo una a una economía que
también tiene sus valores y tiene sus
intereses y américa latina con con
decisiones propios para tomar estas
decisiones lo que han visto varios es
algo se llama capital paciente y capta
paciente puede restar muy complicado y
eso es cuando las tomas decisiones de
inversión extranjera viene muy a la mano
a veces también hay que pensar mucho más
allá mucho más al fondo de cuáles son
sus valores de intereses a largo plazo y
corto plazo y a veces los políticos es
muy difícil tomar esas decisiones porque
lo que quiere es ganar elecciones pero
en realidad
cuando pensamos en los países naciones y
eso es la nueva el mundo global que
estamos viviendo que cada país tiene que
decidir por sí mismo cuál es el tipo de
modelo cuáles son los valores de cada
quien y cómo lo van a promover para
tener generaciones y generaciones
justamente lo que está diciendo qué edad
es cierto o sea hay una percepción de
eeuu
mayoría blanco y
protestante y tienen unos valores
específicas lo que es estos niños además
es un estado donde entramos a un sistema
donde pueden transiciones a personas
criaturas de diferentes formas y
entenderla en entre la lógica en eeuu y
es una parte del valor donde abrimos a
varias personas distintas de diferentes
niveles de esos y económicos
participaciones entonces es un sistema
abierta y esa aventura de responder a
tus necesidades es algo fundamental que
que no hay no hay nada de debatir
que eleve en la ciudad de washington
usted mencionaba a los aliados a nivel
internacional de eeuu durante el
gobierno trump hubo un notable y notorio
distanciamiento por ejemplo con un
aliado importante alemania dentro de la
unión europea la misma ex canciller
alemana angela merkel decía eeuu ya no
es el aliado que teníamos antes la
relación cambio pero vemos al presidente
by the end
convocando por ejemplo a una cumbre
mundial por la democracia
presente en estos foros internacionales
sobre medio ambiente en gira por países
de europa y tratando hablar con los
líderes europeos con el presidente macro
con el primer ministro johnson del reino
unido
está en estos esfuerzos de eeuu bien en
ruta 2 para recuperar a estos aliados
internacionales dará frutos pronto son
solamente 4 años de gobierno que tendrá
el presidente by den para recuperar ese
por lo menos recuperar la conexión con
los aliados
mira el presente bailan y su gobierno se
están dedicando a esto y se están
dedicando a reconstruir las alianzas
como dije de los países que
tradicionalmente han sido aliados eeuu y
si hubo daño en el que el gobierno
anterior por la actitud agresiva de eeuu
que entonces yo creo que sí pero lo que
lo que dicen esos países que si
confiamos en usted presente baile pero y
después de usted que viene entonces son
buenas preguntas pero digo yo que la
institucionalidad de eeuu ya superó la
amenaza más aguda que ha habido en que
la historia por lo menos de este siglo
quiero hacer un comentario también sobre
lo de china y américa latina por un lado
china es un país económico con una
economía grande que compra muchos
insumos y que
productos de 'las de américa latina es
un socio económico lo que los países
latinoamericanos siempre van a velar por
sus propios intereses económicos y eso
es eso está bien pero hay algo que china
de hoy no es el chile de hace 10 años
así ese año será un país en pleno
desarrollo
y bastante libertad interna esto ha
cambiado en la economía de china no es
la misma y la situación interna es mucho
más cerrada entonces y por lado de eeuu
nosotros hemos trabajado durante los
años para superar parte de nuestra
historia que no ha sido buena
entregamos el canal de panamá a panamá y
los panameños lo están manejando bien
nosotros
negociamos tratados de libre comercio
con nuestros vecinos con mexico con cola
con canadá con otros países del
continente y eso en base a intereses
reales entonces yo creo que la relación
y la base para la relación de entre eeuu
y américa latina es mucho más sólida
mucho más moderna
mucho más apta para el futuro y los
intereses de los países de la región y
de eeuu
interesante ese punto que le pregunto a
lorenza aquí en el estudio
tal vez la percepción que hay vuelvo al
tema américa latina' la relación con
china y eeuu es las necesidades que
tiene américa latina' la necesidad de
mejorar la infraestructura por ejemplo
es un punto clave para la región no hay
carretera no hay aeropuertos no hay
puertos de gran calado hay una necesidad
de actualizar la infraestructura eeuu
está un poco igual con este plan que
acaba de aprobar el presidente y el
congreso para poder modernizar la
infraestructura del país pero ahí es
donde entra china jugar la inversión es
completamente distinta entran a
mejorar la infraestructura de los países
eeuu
entra es a crear empresas o por el lado
privado tal vez lo que se percibe es que
la inversión es distinta o la forma
aproximarse es distinta si
definitivamente es un modelo distinto
económicamente y como mencioné antes no
vamos a poder competir con china en esas
inversiones públicas grandes ellos
tienen la capacidad de movilizar
millones de
para inversiones grandes nosotros
podemos ofrecer la oportunidad a nuestro
sector privado pero el gobierno de los
eeuu no puede lo que podemos asegurar es
que las reglas del juego
son transparentes
abiertos sin corrupción y eso es que
estamos como
abogando para cambiar el ritmo en
latinoamérica ahora para muchos no se
puede ver esto entonces es la percepción
que china tiene la raya que dice que
esta carretera fue construido para
porque el cine y la gente de ciudad
china está aquí eeuu no si estamos pero
definitivamente tenemos que hacer más y
dejar estos temas puramente defensivos y
ofrecer algo real
el público y mostrar los resultados
positivos de la democracia hablar mucho
de los problemas en esta región en los
últimos décadas es que las promesas de
la democracia y lo y el libre mercado
no ha no ha actualizado para la mayoría
de la gente y no se han cumplido en la
mayoría de los países de américa latina
todavía hay muchas deudas pendientes me
queda un minuto para terminar el
programa paso a las conclusiones para el
cierre doctor smith su conclusión final
de este debate hay un declive no lo hay
simplemente hay una actualización de un
nuevo escenario internacional y eeuu se
está ajustando o definitivamente está
cediendo terreno usted como lo concluye
yo creo que lo haría aquí en esos años
estar madurando y es un sistema parte
este es tema global y participar en el
sistema global hay que entender la
lógica interna y es muy compleja la
interna nuestras muse y hay que
entenderla externamente también entonces
con mucho gusto muchas gracias para
estar aquí y que el epp su conclusión
del debate y mi conclusión es que
definitivamente no estamos en declive
tenemos nuestros retos internos y
externos pero seguimos siendo eeuu y el
futuro para mí yo lo veo con optimismo
futuro con optimismo y lawrence aquí en
el estudio de su conclusión bueno para
como bueno exdiplomático yo voy a decir
participar tino entonces yo creo que si
seguimos siendo la luz para los países
con la democracia y con la esperanza al
mismo tiempo tenemos que adoptar a un
mundo en que no somos el único país
dominante en el escenario y tenemos que
responder a las necesidades del pueblo
latinoamericano
uno basado en ese concepto bueno pues a
lawrence aquí en el estudio a los
doctores media que le ven la ciudad de
washington les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros y analizado este
tema para la audiencia de france 24 en
toda américa latina ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
y por supuesto sigan viendo france24
[Música]